you're stupid if you're fat oh boy one
of those guys this is because it's so
easy to lose weight tell me more Troy
any type of nuts most people would be
surprised that nuts have a lot of fats
and calories in them they're not a
healthy food that you might think I'm
sorry the 90s cold and it wants its
fat-free diet plan back nut consumption
is actually consistently not linked with
weight gain in fact research suggests
that those who consumed two or more
portions of nuts per week had 31 percent
lower risk of weight gain and even in
studies when nuts were added to the diet
and total calories were not controlled
nut consumption still didn't lead to
weight gain so this is so old school
that it hurts being super fit and slim
really just came down to no soda no
fried chicken and no nuts sure I guess
it really would be super easy but let's
chat again when you've done some
homework on socioeconomic factors
hormones sleep stress scarcity mentality
compensatory mechanisms and reward
system dysfunctions and honestly be
careful who you call stupid because fat
phobias not a cute look